hey what is up everybody it's axelbeatz
here for anime uproar and that means
it's time for another jiu jitsu kaizen
video for those wondering last week
shonen jump wasn't released i think it's
because they had obon in japan but we
are back in high gear with chapter 155
called passion
if you enjoy this video and want to see
more jiu jitsu kaizen content on this
channel be sure to leave a like and if
you're new here or if you just haven't
subscribed to anime uproar yet make this
the video that you do so and be sure to
click that bell and select all
notifications you can also follow anime
uproar on twitter and instagram at anime
uproar or you can follow myself at
excellionyt of course this video will
contain jiu jitsu kaizen spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned now i know last week i made
a joke about how hakari might be setting
up itadori for a pyramid scheme when he
offered him to make a million yen every
month working an hour a day so when the
conversation continued this week with
you just need to give me 200 000 yen for
me to tell you how i actually burst out
laughing however it seems like this was
more of a segue into a discussion on
hikari's philosophy more so than getting
yuji to recruit three of his friends and
having them recruit three of their
friends so they can all get rich
together hikari goes on to talk about
how the most important thing to him is
passion when it comes to scams like
pyramid schemes or anything else the
only thing that allows them to succeed
is the passion in those being fooled and
those fooling them in hopes that they
can change their own lives forever to
him it seems like any action can be
excusable if it's done with passion
whether you are scamming people or being
scammed while he might not like the
result he can at least understand the
drive that it takes to make those moves
and the most heightened form of this of
course is gambling risking it all in
hopes of winning big and changing your
life forever people get carried away by
their passion and make rash decisions so
it's something to be cautious of but at
the same time without passion you can't
even fall in love
he explains it's all a balancing act and
some people just can't keep their
balance but to hikari life is gambling a
series of making decisions and taking
risks to achieve your dream and anyone
who says that they hate gambling
just doesn't understand things correctly
they love gambling too what they hate is
loss that sometimes comes with it and
this whole monologue comes to a peak
with him saying that he loves passion
and that passion is gambling and
gambling is life and that love is
control it's a pretty interesting
perspective to take and although we've
only seen a little bit of akari so far
i'm kinda digging him i feel like he's
going to be a very self-serving
character and that might open the doors
to him siding with whoever might benefit
him the most in that situation and that
could have some very chaotic
implications in this way he sort of
reminds me of hisoka from hunter hunter
understanding how the world works and
using that to put yourself in the most
advantageous position maybe and
hopefully the parallel isn't exactly
one-for-one
[Music]
but the methodical chaos vibe is
definitely still here rather than
hisoka's drive for powerful opponents
though hikari wants to control the
country's passion with his fight club if
he can just make people love his fight
club he will gain control of them
just think about all the people you know
who are die hard sports fans or fans of
games for example they are passionate
and part of their world revolves around
that property
in a way that industry behind it
controls part of their lives
and as such they have some control over
the risks and actions that people are
willing to take it's a very interesting
philosophy that i want to see expanded
on more hakari feels that now is the
time to put his plan into action the
public has learned about her spirits to
some extent so there's surely going to
be interest in the idea of these
sorcerers who fight those spirits
fighting each other and jiu jitsu
headquarters is slowly crumbling so
there really isn't anyone who can get in
the way of these plans but he can't make
these moves alone so he asks itadori to
become his pawn and get swept away by
his passion itadori remembers back to
megami telling him to be discreet about
jujitsu high and as they've been talking
about gambling this whole time he begins
asking for a croupier wanting a second
opinion on what's going on however they
get cut off as hikari's phone starts
rigging and a clear suspicion crosses
his face and here we get a situation
which both shows off how clever hikari
is and how naive itadori is hikari
offers him a drink and asked if he knew
that gojo can't handle his liquor and
itadori who is still only thinking of
distancing himself from jiu jitsu high
in hikari's eyes asks who's gojo
pretending to not know him at first
glance this might seem like the best
thing he could have said however then
you remember that gojo is effectively a
rock star in the jujutsu world every
sorcerer alive knows who he is so
pretending not to know him was probably
the most suspicious thing that itadori
could have done leading to hikari
immediately knowing that he is from
jujutsu high and going on the offensive
and here we get the first glimpse of his
curse technique as sliding doors appear
at itadori's sides and slam closed
trying to smash into itadori it seems
that just like toto's clapping hikari
actually has to slide his hands together
to make these doors closed which is kind
of neat it also kind of reminds me of
the kuchi sakayona which is the spirit
that ghetto was using that had scissors
which worked in similar ways although
this seems to be a bit less effective
version of that in that one is doors and
the other is giant scissors he
eventually manages to pin itadore's neck
and arm between the doors in what is
effectively a pillory before kicking him
across the face and explaining that a
call from kirara was a clear sign for
emergency itadore breaks free for a
moment and bashes his head into hikaris
before calling out for him to listen as
hakari says that he just doesn't want to
just as that battle reaches its climax
we hop over to megami and panda on the
roof with kirara megami is pleading with
kirara and explaining that right now
they aren't from jujutsu high they're
just people who are trying to solve a
massive act of jiu jitsu terrorism and
to do that they need hikari's help
however kirara doesn't seem too
interested as apparently the higher-ups
are the ones who chose to leave him and
hikari out in the first place so if they
didn't want their help then they don't
need it now panda explains that the
higher-ups are very conservative both in
stance on regulation and in how jujutsu
is to be used he says that nobara's
curse technique is the perfect example
of what they like to see while things
like hearst videos or hakaria's
techniques are example of what they hate
to see i would kind of like a bit more
clarification on what this means i
understand like the cursed video thing
but i'm not sure the intrinsic
difference between nobara's technique
and khakari's technique so maybe a
little bit of a better definition would
have been great here also a quick side
note which might just be a translation
issue or could also be a sign of hope or
i could just be reading too much into
things we've been given some vague hints
leading to the idea of nobara being dead
i believe last time they brought it up
it was met by solemn sadness rather than
ah she's recovering she'll be fine or
even she's recovering but we'll see how
it goes but here panda says kugisaki's
curse technique is a model jujutsu that
conservatives would like is not was like
they would say for a dead person like i
said it might just be my english teacher
brain going into overdrive but this
section might also be a hint that nobara
is returning words matter but we'll see
how much it's also interesting that they
chose her specifically when so many
characters exist that there has to be
another good example out there so why
would you choose a dead girl heck even
with megami being a zenin i'm assuming
his own abilities would be a better
example plus it would just be good use
of literary technique to bring her up
shortly before we learn the truth either
way kirara is not having it clearly
angry at how hikari was treated in the
past and sure that no matter what
happens gojo will just clean up their
mess anyways
so why even bother coming to them for
help just that in itself is suspicious
but that's when megami drops the bomb
that gojo was sealed and that's why they
lost in the first place we get this
panel where kirara looks both shocked
and on the verge of bursting out
laughing at the idea that gojo could
have been defeated and clearly he still
doesn't believe them realizing that
talking is going to get them nowhere
megami decides to change things up as he
uses rabbit escape to summon a horde
no a murder of bunnies much better
however it doesn't look like he's gonna
be using them offensively at all he
looks kind of embarrassed almost like
he's pouting a little bit saying that he
needs to persuade kirara so negotiations
with hakari can go further now this
could go in two ways firstly he could
just be trying to win over kira with
some cute animals this would 100 work on
me but i don't think it's likely what's
going on here second and much more
likely he might be trying to overwhelm
kirara's curse technique if how the
ability works has to do with people who
have been marked or if there's a limit
on how many things can be repelled with
this effect then sending dozens and
dozens of bunnies at him might be a good
solution either way i am curious to see
what happens next as this is where the
chapter comes to a close while not a lot
happened in the grand scheme of the
story this chapter we did get a few
things that i really appreciate and that
really stood out to me is very important
firstly the monologue from hikari gave
us a glimpse at who he really was or at
least his philosophies and how he sees
the world around him which i really
liked we also got to see his ability to
think quickly as he gets itadore to
expose himself and not to mention we
also got to see our first look at his
curse technique which was pretty simple
but very cool we got what might be a
hint of nobara still being alive and of
course we had kirara being confronted
with the reality that gojo is sealed
even if he doesn't believe it things
have been progressing towards the climax
and i think next chapter should be the
moment where everything comes to a head
and god am i excited is it next week yet
nope let me know what you guys think of
this chapter as well as hikari's curse
technique the idea of nobara still being
alive and most importantly what do you
think megami will do with his murder of
bunnies if you enjoyed this jujutsu
kaizen video and want to see more please
leave a like and if you're new to anime
uproar remember to subscribe and ring
that bell by selecting all notifications
you can guarantee that you will not miss
any future videos and of course you can
always follow anime uproar at anime
uproar on twitter or instagram or you
can follow myself at excellionyt i want
to give a big thank you to all of our
anime uproar patrons who make videos
like this one possible special thanks to
alpha sigma who is an absolute mad lad
and disciple of lord tuigo himself and
of course are the one tier patrons the
ones who rise above all other clans
these being ingrata patahepha al-jatal
hinokami and water the toasted chi the
spike
8227 dylan isadore spidey life tennelle
tungsten tarcus baked buddhist and
monkey d quilly and finally thank you to
all of our pro hero tier patrons the one
and only gilgamesh the red haired raven
angel cruise ratherwin de ora very gucci
alicia octor bonnie parks joanne garcia
ted not ted fatboy games corey mcgowan
and soul ray slice and dice if you enjoy
our videos and feel like they provide
some kind of value to you please
consider checking out our patreon
through the link in the description
anyone who supports the channel with
even a single dollar has access to our
exclusive patreon only discord and your
name will appear at the end of videos
just like all of these phenomenal people
but for now i want to thank you all so
much for watching and until next time
remember to stay active
[Music]
bye